foreign
hey what's going on you guys oh [__]
this like this [__] is in the [__]
chat okay yeah
oh well how much I've been like that I
don't know I don't know I think I put it
down closer because I was recording like
some other stuff yeah all right so we
got some people there we can just go
ahead and roll with this
um we saw the uh second part of Shazam
yeah like I said remember I said it's
like oh we're gonna try and do like
horror movies and stuff but then I was
on HBO Max and then I was like hey Tom
they just put the new Shazam the like
the second shazam movie up there which I
totally forgotten about and he's like oh
okay let's watch that yeah so uh we
watched that instead yeah we saw the
first one in the theater yeah a couple
times right yeah I think we saw it twice
and um I loved it I know a lot of people
well not a lot of people but some people
kind of like didn't like the tone of
this movie uh they didn't think it
matched the tone of the other stuff in
the DC Universe I didn't care I just I
liked the movie I thought it was a a fun
superhero movie yeah it's it's uh
it's kind of corny but it's supposed to
be you know it's I don't really take a
superhero [__] seriously it's just fun
and uh
this one's fun so we saw the uh the
sequel
and um I Heard mixed eggs about it
and uh I liked it I thought it was great
yeah I ended up enjoying it quite a lot
like I said I had kind of forgotten
about it coming out because like I said
I really liked the first one and I think
the um what people liked about the first
one and what I liked about the first one
is that it was a superhero movie but it
didn't concentrate so much on
um you know like big spectacle or and it
didn't take itself real seriously it was
kind of more concerned with Shazam and
with like his whole thing of like the
kid being given super powers and all
that other kind of stuff so
um so I feel like what ended up
happening with this one because the
first one was like really really
successful that I came out back in 2019
and they pretty much immediately started
working on a sequel but then because of
like you know covid and then they kept
shuffling it around you know so it
wouldn't compete with other big movies
like Aquaman and uh you know and Avatar
and stuff like that so it ended up not
getting released until recently now it's
only been on HBO Max I didn't notice
until yesterday but it's only been on
HBO Max for less than a month I think it
came on there like at the end of May of
2023. yeah I wish it had come out right
after the first one
to keep the momentum
yeah I don't know how well this did at
the box office uh not at all it only
made um 133 million dollars yeah uh
worldwide and the budget of it was like
125 million yes it did make his money
back so it's because it's considered a
bomb yeah and the thing about it like I
read a few reviews of it and I watched
Oliver Harper's review and stuff like
that most people seem to like like it
but not as much as the first one they I
think the main complaint was that one it
was too overstuffed like the um the
story was like too complicated for the
kind of movie that it was and um that
some plot threads just kind of were left
hanging or were unresolved and I think
that they didn't like that um it seemed
to lean more into being like a spectacle
movie more like the Marvel movies like
you know with big dragons and all this
other kind of stuff whereas I think what
people liked about the first movie was
kind of like the more heart of it like
the more character based kind of stuff
which they have a lot of in this movie
too so I can see people's criticism
systems but honestly I had a really good
time watching this movie I thought it
was really fun I mean and I don't think
that was just the alcohol talking
because we were drinking quite a bit but
you know you know I liked it yeah I had
a good time with it I also liked Black
Adam and evidently people didn't like
that one
um but I heard I don't know if this is
true or not but I heard that Black Adam
was supposed to be the villain in this
movie yeah and then there was some kind
of contractual something or other and
like it didn't work out so in this one
Black Adam is not in this one he's not
mentioned in this one
um it's actually like new villains it's
three Greek goddesses essentially yeah
like the daughters of Atlas yes and one
of them's this hot old lady
Helen Mirren Helen Mirren she was in uh
Excalibur she played Morgana the uh yeah
King Arthur's uh half-sister who is a
evil sorceress
and that was like she was like a 1970s
Proto goth outfit type chick she had a
blonde hair and the
uh fish nets and
kind of wearing
I think she she wore a little sorceress
outfit in the old Excalibur she was
great in it she was hot but tell you
what she's like in her mid 70s she's
still smoking hot she was great she's in
good shape had some work done probably
but man you recognize her that's her
elegant looking woman I mean Helen
Mirren she's like a legend yeah like and
she I didn't even know this but
apparently she was in some of the Fast
and the Furious movies I didn't know
that either so I didn't know that yeah
but yeah she's so she's still working so
yeah she's one of the villains in this
Lucy Liu is uh the other one yeah and um
the the girl that was in the new West
Side Story yeah I don't know is the uh
the Steven Spielberg one she's uh she's
one of the sisters also which you know
is that a spoiler I guess
[Laughter]
kind of I guess it's kind of a spoiler
but yeah it's a like I said I don't want
to get too much into
like what happens at the end or nothing
like that because I feel like this is a
pretty new movie and probably a lot of
people haven't seen it but honestly
um yeah I mean the whole plot of the
movie they don't really like I said they
don't
um it's been a while since we've seen
the other one but the whole thing with
the staff and The Wizard guy
that happened at the in the first one
right yeah like the staff got broken I
did kind of remember that
um so that kind of like comes back into
play in this one at the very beginning
like two of the villains who were like
the daughters of Atlas which is Helen
Mirren and Lucy Liu uh they steal this
broken staff from a museum in Athens I
guess in Greece and then they're gonna
use it to
take their power take the powers away of
yeah because I guess I guess what
happened was like the wizard had like he
had the staff and he used it to give
Shazam Powers Yeah to Champions and they
were like those those are our powers and
you can't have yeah
right right right so that's kind of what
they were trying to do and then there
was also kind of like a side well I
don't know it was like a related Mission
or like a side mission where they were
also looking for that Golden Apple thing
like the seed because they wanted to
restore their world except there was
some conflict with the villains because
I guess Helen Mirren and the and the
younger one
uh Anthea was the name of the younger
sister like they kind of just wanted to
restore their realm or whatever whereas
Lucy Liu who was like the evil one her
name was Calypso I think and she wanted
to plant the seed in the earth so it
would [__] up like and make the Earth
their realm so it would like essentially
kill everybody I guess or like [__] up
the planet you know what I mean yeah so
um so yeah it was something like that it
was something like that like it's not
important it's not important there's not
a little like McGuffin type things and
we're gonna do this and that it never
really comes to anything but uh you know
they're the bad guys the bad guys are
constantly threatened and [__] and you
don't you're not fully you can't fully
Envision what it is they're talking
about but there's a good final fight
scene between Shazam
well his buddies were in it too they got
super powers but um they call them the
shazamiley did you know that this is
Emily yeah okay yeah
and uh I didn't make that up that's what
they call them he has a a big uh
big Showdown with uh evil sorceress
who's riding on a dab dragon a wooden
Dragon he's wood yeah okay like that's
what all those like shapes and stuff are
supposed to be wood
yeah look I thought it was just horn but
it's wood okay the uh
it's it's a good fight scene it goes
kind of Kaiju you know like yeah
Godzilla movie it did kind of yeah
but um you know I thought it was a
satisfied movie it's just a fun movie
fun superhero movie yeah it was just oh
you know was it as good as the first one
I don't know maybe not but um there were
different kind of movies but they were
kind of different kind of movies this
one like I said kind of was more it had
all of the fun stuff with like you know
all the um characters and them being kid
although I will say that Billy Batson he
didn't really get much kid time he was
pretty much Shazam it's the same actor
yeah yeah okay yeah every I think
everybody was the same I don't think
they replaced anybody yeah um as far as
I know and like I looked on the
Wikipedia page and they didn't say that
anybody had been replaced so I guess it
was all the same because I couldn't
remember because it's supposed to be
four years like you know which I guess
is that's how it's like supposed to be
in the movie Universe it's supposed to
be four years later
and um so for a second like when I saw
Billy Batson like as the kid form I was
like wait is that the same kid I was
like it kind of looks like the same kid
but I couldn't really tell it's been a
while since we see because it's been a
while so it's like I couldn't tell if it
was the same kid but apparently it is
the same kid okay but um but yeah that
was kind of one thing is like that you
didn't really see him in his he's in it
like as a kid but you don't see him as
much in it as you probably did in the
first one but one thing I will say
though like the kid and I might have
said this about the first movie as well
the kid that plays Freddy
um you know his best friend yeah with
the with the crutch that kid's awesome I
love that I think he's probably like the
best character I think he was the best
character in the first one too like he's
just funny as [__] he has like great
comic timing and he's in this a lot
because there's kind of like a little
subplot where
he's like at school and he falls for
this girl and you know that kind of
whole thing goes sideways a little bit
but um but yeah so he's great and
honestly like some of the some of the
scenes of him like where really bad [__]
is happening like his reactions and [__]
like that are really good like he's just
a really good it's a shame that this
movie didn't do well at the box office
because we'll probably not get another
one yeah because I think they were
supposed to be like making other ones
yeah but now the whole future of it is
like up in the air because they don't
know because this one kind of had a
little bit of a crossover slightly with
Wonder Woman yeah Wonder Woman's in it
like um just they just had like a small
like a cameo in there yeah what's his
name Billy badass Billy
Madison is his name right yeah
he's got a huge crush on uh Wonder Woman
he's only uh 18. he's 17 going on 18.
yeah and he's [__] fantasizing and
dreaming about being on a date with
[__] Wonder Woman it's not gonna work
out he he turns her down and she [__]
gives him the cold shoulder in his
dreams you know that wasn't fun yeah she
she does eventually show up in it though
what a woman and it's Gal Gadot yeah
whether it's unit so it's the original
actress
you know
it sucks that
sucks and it didn't do out the box
office
it didn't deserve to do badly at the
bottom box office if you asked me I
thought it was decent movie
yeah I've certainly seen way worse
movies that did a lot better yeah I mean
this one was actually really fun I had a
lot of fun with it it wasn't for it's
long I will say that it's like two hours
and 11 minutes but it wasn't boring or
nothing I've seen worse Marvel movies
this isn't a Marvel movie it's a DC
movie somebody mentioned in Marvel this
is DC I've seen worst Marvel movies much
worse at uh Miss Marvel I thought that
movie was really Bland I thought that
sucked uh this one I thought had a lot
more character to it you know it was a
fun movie yeah it's I think it didn't
have it wasn't quite as Charming as the
first one but it's still like pretty
still pretty fun and it's like way more
fun usually than like the Marvel movies
are I feel like yeah Marvel movies
they're not that fun I don't really like
them that much yeah this one is just
like kind of goofy and
this one's out it's not as goofy as the
first one because it kind of has a
little bit more like serious stuff in
there so I get better in Shang she was
in a chang she the uh wasn't that oh
yeah the Chinese the Rings yeah that was
that one that one was all right they
have a totally forgettable though yeah
just forgettable a lot of the Marvel
stuff's just kind of generic yeah um
although I did like the one uh the
Spider-Man one yeah where uh Doctor
Strange brought all the damn
Spider-Man villains had been killed
brought him back to life yeah yeah yeah
and then some kind of weird Universal
crossover type of deal yeah the
Spider-Mans have been like yeah
Spider-Man's pretty good thing but like
I haven't really seen a lot of the
Marvel ones yeah like I you know
sometimes I'll go see them and sometimes
not it's like I'm just kind of
ambivalent about it yeah but I think
when we saw the first Shazam
and we I think we said this when we saw
the first Aquaman too is that I kind of
liked that DC seemed like they were
going like in a more fun Direction yeah
you know I mean like they made the
movies more fun whereas Marvel you know
the the Marvel movies have like some
humor in them and stuff like that but I
kind of feel like they take themselves
more seriously you know what I mean like
they're trying to do this big World
building thing which DC is trying to do
too but at least they kind of like have
more fun with it I feel like DC's I mean
some people some people could say that
the DC Universe is a [__] mess it
might be because where's Joker fit in
with this you know what Batman is that
because that last Batman that came out
which I thought was okay
didn't have anything to do with the
joker no so you're gonna run two
different Batman movies if they ever
redo the Joker within Batman's in it
again
I don't know how do you clean this up I
don't really we think we need any more
Batman movies
yeah I would I would love to see another
Joker movie
I heard they were making one really yeah
I'd love to see that would Batman be in
it which one would it be yeah I don't
know yeah I don't know but it seems kind
of like the DC stuff they're kind of
like uh
a la carte type movies they
yeah whatever you don't necessarily have
to fit it with any of the other stuff
but this one even though the tone of
Shazam
is unlike the tone of say Wonder Woman
Wonder Woman is in this because I guess
each story is told from its own
perspective and because these are kind
of young fun
kids that got superpowers that turned
them into adults when they yell Shazam
it's kind of a goofy premise
but you can have a lot of fun with that
so the story is told with a lot of kind
of humor
but there are real bad guys in it you
know like they were gonna have black
Black Adam was going to be in it you
know because that is a Shazam villain
yeah
um
they were gonna it crosses over you know
in the comics and also in the animated
uh cartoons out there's some animated
movies with Shazam I want to see him
they look pretty good
Superman shows up in him yeah Superman
and Shazam Superman's trying to keep
Shazam in check or something something
like that because Shazam they kind of
have a lot of crossover in terms of
powers they're about as strong as each
other
um and shazam's a [__] up basically
compared to Superman
well yeah because he's a kid yeah you
know what I mean in the comic book He's
supposed to be kind of a [__] up too
he's kind of yeah but see that's
Superman is more like a cop in a way
where he tried to keep everything in
order well I mean because Superman he
like he's an alien and he's like a kind
of a goody two-shoes type of thing
unless like in the newer ones yeah they
kind of like darken him up a little bit
but it's like
um I kind of feel like like I said the
reason that people like Shazam so much
is because it was kind of like a breath
of fresh air it's a great premise and I
think like all the actors and it's all
the same actors like I said the same the
kid same kid actors on the same adult
actors they did a really good job in the
adult roles of like
um coming across as though they were
children in adult bodies I think they
they nailed that it's good enough yeah I
I think they did a good job it's like um
honestly Freddy
he's mostly in his kid form in this one
which like I said is fine because I love
that kid he's like he's hilarious but in
his adult form it kind of cracks me up
because he's isn't he called like
Captain every powers or something yeah
he's got all the power
and then but I mean there was a lot of
[__] that I really liked in this one I
really liked their um their Lair like
that they've made in the sense because
that wasn't in the first one right so
this is something that he was in it they
didn't they didn't let you know that it
was that big right that you could go
behind those statues there were other
dimensions in there yeah their whole
yeah there was like a whole other
Library I loved the the sentient pen
whose name was Steve yeah uh I loved
that whole sequence where they were
writing the letter
that's dictated they're addicting to the
pen like they were writing the letter to
the to the daughters of Atlas telling
people like please not kill everybody
like which which such a kid thing to do
and it's like funny because Steve the
pen would write down whatever he said so
it's like whenever they you know said
you know should we like say that or
something like he would write down
everything and then like Helen Mirren is
reading this letter with all of these
sides in it and it's like that was like
super funny
so I really really liked that
um I like I could have done without uh
the the Skittles thing
the Skittles placement though is come on
man they they Skittles had to [__]
they well they didn't get its [__]
money it's a whole crossover I heard
that they I haven't seen them but I
heard like Skittles even did commercials
with Shazam characters that's a good
idea though because it's like yeah it's
there's there's a point in there where
they're feeding Skittles to like
unicorns right unicorns yeah because
there was yeah because there's one point
where it's kind of like a Monster Mash
where there's like all the ancient Greek
monsters like Cyclops and uh manticores
and harpies and stuff like that yeah and
there's a shout out to the uh Ray
harryhausen Cyclops that's when they
start releasing the Greek monsters onto
the Earth one up there it's definitely
Ray harryhausen's yeah that looks pretty
much just like the rare and it was
pretty much Ray harryhausen's um uh
harpies
yeah now that you mention it yeah now
that you mention it the heartbeats did
look like like they weren't because like
I said this was going toward the end of
the movie and it was just kind of like
they were just kind of they weren't even
the main thing like I said the main
thing was kind of like the dragon with
Loosely writing on it but yeah Lucy Liu
is looking pretty good too she's got to
be close to 60 by now
I think she's older than me I don't know
man yeah I remember seeing her in movies
like a long time yeah yeah she's still
in good shape
and we were talking about Helen Mirren
too because I said you know I knew that
you would know who she was from uh
Excalibur but I was like when I was in
the UK I remember she was on that show
um Prime Suspect and I remember really
liking that a lot I think that was back
in the 90s I want to say yeah and it was
like more than one I don't remember if
she was in all of them or not but I
think it was like based on those novels
but um but yeah it's like it's kind of
sad because uh what kanak was saying and
said from what I understand and this is
from yeah I heard this as well uh the
rock messed up Shazam because he changed
a lot of the plot of Black Adam that
originally was supposed to tie into the
Shazam Series yeah that's kind of along
the lines of what I heard as well yeah
the rock I think helped fund Shazam
though didn't he he did yeah I think he
was a producer he was a producer yeah
so you kind of can have the right to do
whatever he wants it's his [__] he owned
it but you know it sucks I mean
hopefully look they're gonna have to
bring Shazam back because you know the
Rock's gonna want to do another Black
Adam movie I think Black Adam did okay I
think if I remember correctly I don't
know yeah I don't know did we review
Black Adam didn't we because I know we
watched it I liked it I think it did
okay
I mean hopefully you know they make
money on streaming over time too that's
true so
you know it's not the big score that
they look for they want to make all
their money in the first couple [__]
weeks you know walk off with a billion
dollars
some of this [__] is their fault they
spend too much money on these movies
Yeah well yeah that's kind of and now it
has to everybody in the world has to
[__] see it in order for it to make
its money back and they don't like to
make its money back they like to take
they like to make triple triple what
they pay
and man that's
that's a tall order it's a tall order in
today's society where you know AMC
theater is [__] constantly getting
bailed out by dudes with what with
[__] Dogecoin and [__] those coin on
on [__] uh uh
stock trading at stocks stock trading
apps and [__] that's what saved AMC AMC
was gonna [__] just vanish
um and that's a major [__] movie
theater chain here in the United States
it's just it's a miracle we still have
theaters
after [__] covet
yeah and there are some States where
people just don't go out they're staying
home still
Tammy says Lucy Liu is only 54. 54. okay
so she's my age so she's like yeah yeah
that's why she looks so good
[Laughter]
yeah yeah she's only a couple years
older than I am yeah
uh Pat says I'm with Jenny on the Batman
movies enough is enough yeah it's like
how much can you really do with that I
feel like because Batman is just like a
guy you know what I mean with a lot of
money and like cool gadgets and stuff
um you can't do as much as you can with
like a supernatural like a superhero
that has like magical powers you know
what I mean I feel like there's more
room to explore
you know once you introduce like
Supernatural [__] and because I feel
like Batman
even though he's in the DC Universe and
technically yeah Superman is in there
and he's well you know Superman isn't
technically like Supernatural he's an
alien right yeah but I don't know I kind
of feel like once you into like the
Shazam thing I mean that's pretty much
magic powers there's a Batman versus
Superman movie I saw that had Ben
Affleck in it I think things the guy's
name yeah we watched that I saw the
director's cut not the one that was in a
theatrical cut it was still it was okay
Batman was fighting Superman he was in a
special armor and [__]
but you know whatever I kind of feel
like anybody versus Superman like
Superman's gonna win Superman [__] you
up like he can do he has all the powers
he's
basically a guy he's a God yeah so it
ain't gonna happen uh but they guess
they kind of pulled it off with that
movie
um
if you ask me Batman can only be in
certain kinds of stories because
basically what you're dealing with is a
detective
the detective with a bunch of money he's
uh even the shadow had more Powers than
he had the shadow could Cloud your mind
had psychic abilities and [__] sorry uh
and he was a detective
uh the closest other thing the closest
one to Batman would just be the Punisher
Punisher used guns though Batman didn't
yeah that's what I mean they're just
guys they don't have magical powers yeah
they just happen to have like tools and
stuff The Punisher did have a secret he
did his secret power was his head injury
but that's not magical not magical no I
mean he couldn't just go pushing like
you know throw somebody against the wall
or something yeah some [__] like that
yeah
but you know that well that's kind of
the thing too and um
in this movie I think it was good
because it was almost like the the
daughters of Atlas who were the villains
I mean obviously they were they were
super super powerful even though it's
like well they were trying to get their
powers back like with the staff or
whatever like take the powers back from
them but I was like I don't know they
seem to be doing pretty good you know
what I mean like they they had like some
kick-ass Powers anyway but because those
powers like had been stolen from them I
guess so I feel like them in the
shazamiley were kind of um evenly
matched they had similar kind of powers
so they could kind of like kick each
other's ass David's in there under a new
name hey what's up it's a might Bowser
yeah okay
um oh Tammy said cute hair Jenny thank
you yeah yeah these
I got these braids well I had these like
poofs before yeah this is real hair
right here but yeah it's a mixture the
braids aren't real the braids aren't
real yeah I got these from Sheen yeah
and I got some I got some different ones
uh too I got some blue ones and some
pink ones show me cute little feet with
your cute little leggings my cute little
feet I can't really because I'm kind of
like oh
help they got little bones and stars and
you can't really see it yeah I can't
really see they're little fuzzy things
yeah a little fuzzy yeah we're doing
photo shoots and videos and whatnot yeah
or that's why we're running late because
we kind of went over doing that but you
know what I mean
um it's probably about that's probably
about it on this though isn't there
probably yeah like I said I don't really
want to spoil it because
um you know it's kind of newish yeah out
and I feel like maybe a lot of people
haven't seen it and like I said it's
kind of a shame because it I really
don't know why it did that badly like
even if you didn't like it as much as
the first one it was still like really
good it was still entertaining it was
still funny it had to be timing and
there's been a bunch of shitty movies
out and theaters have been dead for a
long time so it was just
they should have like streamed this [__]
[__] well though you know they gotta
get make their money back on the
theatrical release well yeah that's the
thing and like I said it did get
shuffled around a lot and it got pushed
back because of various reasons and yada
yada I wouldn't have spent as much money
on it either I'd have made it cheaper
Yeah well yeah that's the thing they did
spend more money on this one and you can
tell because they put a lot more CGI in
this one yeah like they had like like I
said they had a [__] dragons and
unicorns and like all kind of like Greek
monsters and harpies and [__] like that
so they had all that kind of stuff you
know giant Dome over Philadelphia like
yeah all that kind of all that yeah if
you haven't seen the first Shazam I
recommend it see it you can you can get
it on Blu-ray you can stream it on a
couple bucks
um
if you have HBO max they're playing this
right now I don't think I don't know
what it cost on Amazon Prime
probably expensive it's probably 10 15
bucks probably
is it is it still up in the high uh I
don't know actually yeah maybe see the
first one if you haven't seen the first
one you'll like it it's good it's just a
fun movie I still think the first one is
slightly better but I don't really know
um and probably for the same reason that
some people were complaining about is
that
um you know the first one was not like a
Marvel movie in the sense that it was
more character focused and I liked all
of that stuff because like all the
characters were good and but this one
has a lot of that stuff too but you can
tell that they were trying to go like
bigger and better because it's a sequel
I'm not complaining no I'm not either
um
as soon as I saw the first one I loved
it I wanted to see the sequel had I been
able to see it back to back this one I
still would have enjoyed it yeah I
wouldn't have criti wouldn't have
criticized it and said oh yeah that's
cool you know you know I liked it but
I'm I'm very easy going on
on
um
fun superhero movies you know I'm not
real hard on them
um because I'm not a super fan super
fans are [__] real hard on [__] A lot
of times yeah
um
thank you
know like like I like Batman and I never
liked the new Batman that much it was
okay but just
I like the older Batman though that that
last four movies you know you like the
Christopher Nolan Christopher Nolan I
thought they were pretty good
um that's you the last one that was good
now the very first one was the best
though Batman Begins and I thought that
was just an epic flick
the storytelling was [__] perfect
um
[__] Joker was [__] great uh
Superman one two and three the [__]
daughter [__] cut a Superman yeah
Christopher Reeves
the the the Man of Steel the first one
that came out I guess that was 2007 or
something yeah it grew on me when did
that come out I didn't like it that much
when I first saw it I liked it more
later
um then he shows up in another movie I
had to see that one again
but uh anyway I don't know how people
can keep track of all these like this
yeah especially like all the Marvel yeah
ones like I think the last time that we
reviewed a Marvel movie I was actually
like looking at all because I haven't
seen like even a fraction of them yeah
so it's like I'm looking at the [__]
and I'm just like holy [__] like how did
how did they even like keep track of all
of this stuff I can't keep track of all
the [__] my own life and like all
this [__] in there I can't imagine like
keeping track of all in general in
general I prefer the DC characters
yeah you know even though some of the
Marvel movies are really good the
character the characters the heroes in
DC I like them better
I guess because they're just they're
older and they're just kind of more
traditional I guess you know
um you know Iron Man came out when I was
a little kid and it just still kind of
seems to kind of newfangled it's good
but everything seems real high-tech
super high-tech magic and [__]
I like it but not as much as just like
the old school you know he's Superman or
you know what I mean he's that kind of
[__] you know he's an alien he can fly
yeah like he's got magic you know yeah
it's like it's alien he's Batman you
know he's got a lot of money you can
fight
yeah yeah just more simple
but yeah it's you know it's
it's kind of a shame like I said that
this movie didn't do a lot better
because I guess the first one did really
well like obviously because they started
working on the sequel right away but
it's like I kind of feel like they're
probably not even gonna make a third one
now yeah which kind of sucks because
they actually did have
um like a mid-credit sequence and I
think they had a after credit sequence
did we see the after Garden sequence
yeah no maybe we didn't did we yeah I
don't I don't think we watched the
credits all the way we saw the one that
was in the middle yeah okay uh which is
what's his name um
Pat Hatfield says he only likes the
first Superman movie
yeah this the first one was [__]
classic uh two was really good too three
with with uh
with [__] Richard Pryor was the worst
one actually I thought it was kind of
stale
four
with the [__] nuclear man nuclear man
[__] with the Canon film one actually
was like one of the better ones I liked
it I liked it it was [__] cheesy uh
it had terrible special effects
but Chris Reeves [__] did a good job
on it and it had some good ideas in it
it was it was it was wild
I kind of feel like well it skirts uh so
bad it's good territory yeah but that's
mostly because of the villain I don't
think it was a bad idea necessarily they
[__] up they should have they should
have changed that villain up just a
little bit okay it should have just made
it kind of an evil Superman
like a clone
and then um
should have gotten to a kind of
situation where the evil Superman wanted
to be the real Superman
you know what I mean yeah and it should
have been something like that yeah see
that would have been good and they
actually had a relationship and like a
friendship where Superman is trying to
help the new Superman be a good person
but he just can't there's something
wrong with his jacket was DNA is [__]
corrupted or something you know what I
mean it's that way you could have two
Chris Reeves
a lot better
yeah because I mean the thing about it
is that the villain the nuclear Man
villain was just not
intimidating in any way shape or form as
soon as he appeared you're just like
yeah so it's just kind of like I'm like
I'm not scared of that guy you know what
I'm saying it's kind of true to the old
comics in the way though yeah they were
they were [__] corny
but I've heard a lot of people have said
that you're if you have a superhero
movie the superhero movie is only as
good as the villain yeah which is in a
lot in a lot of ways is probably true
yeah in the head Lex Luthor come back in
that one so they had a lot of they had a
a lot of good [__] had good potential
yeah what really lets the movie Down is
the opening credit see sequences you
know like the animated [__] words it
looks shitty as hell it really does so
it just gives you a bad impression right
off the [__] bat because Canon we're
just like like we're always gonna spend
five bucks on yeah we can't spend money
on that so they shouldn't instead of
[__] giving that [__] real epic
opening they should have given a very
simple opening where they didn't have to
show Third Rate yeah if you have the
money to do it then don't go simple just
don't do it because it's gonna look
really bad yeah you know all right let's
shut it down Jim yeah yeah we extend all
we can say about this one yeah that's
true we got you but yeah it's good I
mean yeah there's nothing wrong with it
it's not bad well like I said most of
the reviews that I saw most of the
people said the same thing they were
like well it's good it just wasn't as
good as the first one like I think they
were disappointed if that it wasn't as
good as the first one that's all and um
some yeah Trey said I'm not big on the
superhero movies but I don't bag on them
like others do I love that last Batman
movie though
and Oracle says Christopher Reeves is
still Chris Reeves is still my Superman
yeah I mean I have a hard time like
seeing anybody else in that role because
he just owned it you know yeah he was
Superman yeah basically uh the Mike
Bowser said ducky is his nephew was a
little question yeah oh yeah that's
right and I love that guy I love that
actor what the [__] is that with the guy
that played ducky [__] I know I could I
know his name I just can't think of it
right now but um whatever that accent
was that that he was doing in that movie
was just somebody should have slapped
that right but you know Superman Quest
for Peace man the number four was better
than number three Jon Cryer thank you
that's his name
I say I I enjoyed number four more than
number three
yeah I I could see that I'd have to
watch them all I liked it back to back I
like to yeah three was kind of just
stale yeah
yeah all right so uh yeah we're gonna
wrap it up like I said uh this movie is
on HBO max if you have HBO Max that's
where we watched it and uh it's totally
decent and I've it's kind of a shame
that it didn't do all that well and now
we're probably not gonna get another one
like leave hanging that's [__] sucks
yeah but yeah so um tomorrow is Monday
and that means it's time for a haunting
and we're gonna be doing season six
episode two which is called the Well
from Hell which is weird because
Wikipedia said well to hell and then
when I watched it last night I was like
wait it says the Well from hell is that
I'm just like whatever guess whatever
and uh here's the hilarious thing about
this we actually watched The Haunting
episode last night I said so we don't
have to watch it tonight and um we
watched it after we watched the shazam
movie so we were pretty hammered yeah um
not so hammered that we didn't know was
going on but I was taking notes on the
haunting episode and I was just like
this will be hilarious when we do the
show tomorrow and I'll like read the
notes that drunk me wrote down yeah I
said hopefully they're coherent I
remember the episode I wasn't that drunk
but you know what I mean so I just
thought that was fine and I haven't
looked at the notes yet because I want
it to be a surprise
so uh so yeah uh the well to hell I'll
be there yeah it's or like I said the
Well from Hell whatever it is I don't
know the the actual title says the
welfare Mill but yeah that's the one
we're gonna be doing tomorrow so
hopefully you guys can uh drop by for
that so have a good rest of your evening
you guys and we'll see you again
tomorrow night bye